good morning Hank it's Monday today's
video comes in four parts and one rant
[Music]
how much wood could a woodchuck chuck if
a woodchuck could chuck wood how much
wood could a woodchuck chuck if a
woodchuck could chuck wood I'm just
practicing my vocal dexterity to get
ready for my ranting but first part 1
the Paper Towns giveaway instead of
giving away one book I'm going to give
away two one to a random commenter on
the Ning and one to a random commenter
on YouTube first we're gonna do the Ning
okay I am generating a random number
between 1 and 714 607 601 is Nate 602 is
Samantha 603 is dreamer 604 is Apple 605
is Shelby 606 is Lexie and the winner is
Pablo whose comment was I'd adore a copy
of Paper Towns
and now for YouTube I'm now going to
generate a random number between 1 and
4587 I'm clicking the button now in the
number is 2610 that's gonna be a hard
number to find I was kind of hoping the
number would be like 8 the winner is
YouTube user neo neiser 21 who has 48
hours from the posting of this video to
claim his or her prize otherwise it will
go to someone else part 2 the political
situation in Nepal isn't bad all things
considered Hank for the first time in a
long time Nepal had a free and fair
election even though they chose to elect
a plurality of Maoists who aren't known
for continuing the tradition of free and
fair elections but even so this
represents serious progress for Nepal
and it's also a good thing for me
because it makes it less likely that I
am again going to have to eat toilet
paper is a joke that you only understand
if you've watched all our videos part 2
inside jokes Hank the other day the Yeti
was watching one of our videos and she
said to me you know I live with you and
even so I don't get some of these jokes
and I was like now when you say jokes do
you mean like cool or do you mean like
the plural of joke so I just want to say
to all the new nerdfighters welcome
we're glad you're here it will all make
sense later part 3 Second Life from 5
p.m. to 6 p.m. Eastern u.s. time I'm
going to be in second life more info in
the sidebar or perhaps in the sidebar I
am good at finger mustaches but I am
terrible at remembering where the
sidebar is part 4 I don't
have a part for but I do have a rant um
I understand that there are a lot of
things about human existence that are
extraordinarily arbitrary like whether
or not you get cancer when you're thirty
or whether or not you're born in a rich
country or whether or not when you're 26
you happen to meet the world's hottest
Yeti but just because there are a lot of
unfair things in this world that we
can't do anything about doesn't mean
that we I just used a double negative
doesn't mean that we don't have to do
things about the things that we can do
something about
like for instance health care how do I
know there's a better way because the
United States is the richest country in
the world but we have a higher infant
mortality rate than Slovenia the life
expectancy in America ranks 45th in the
world
we're behind Puerto Rico which has
almost the exact same political system
is us the only major difference is that
all Puerto Ricans have access to health
care whereas millions of Americans don't
so when we think about the importance of
having health care available to all
people that's what's at stake not only
the quality of our lives but the length
of our lives and perhaps more important
that all Hank
Hank is at stake in this debate he has
to go to the hospital and pay for it out
of his own pocket because in order to
try to save money his doctor gave him a
drug that is known to be unsafe that is
almost never prescribed in any of the
countries in Europe that have socialized
medicine and not because he's poor or
because he's lazy or because he's not
trying hard to get health insurance but
because insurance companies literally
will not cover him for any amount of
money and the only thing that he ever
did wrong was be sick there are facets
of illness that are arbitrary and unfair
and cannot be fixed but this is not one
of them now maybe you're saying Hank
could go to work for a big corporation
and he could get health care
the Wright brothers weren't working for
a big corporation that offered benefits
when they invented the airplane in fact
probably the thing that I most like
about America is our entrepreneurial
spirit which is literally being killed
by this healthcare crisis Hank I am
really glad that I'm going to see you on
Wednesday